اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من الجليل الاعلى
اهلا بكم عدد الشهداء جراء الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه يتجاوز 10 الا
ومسؤولون في القطاع يؤكدون تلقي بلاغات عن
عشرات جثامين الشهداء في شوارع مدينه غزه
بعد غارات الليله الماضيه وبلينك يؤكد ان
جهود التوصل الى هدنه انسانيه مستمره عقب
مباحثات في انقره
منظمات امميه ودوليه تحذر من حرمان سكان
غزه من اساسيات الحياه بعد استهداف القصف
الاسرائيلي لمصادر المياه والطاقه الشمسيه
القصف الاسرائيلي يوقف مخابز غزه عن العمل
مع انقطاع امدادات القمح ومنظمات اغاثه
تطالب بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار وادخال عاجل
للمساعدات
كتائب القسا تعلن قصف حشود عسكريه
اسرائيليه شمال غرب بيت لاهيا بالهاون
وتدمير دبابتين اسرائيليتين واربع اليات
متوغل في محيط مدينه غزه بقذائف الياسين
والجيش الاسرائيلي يؤكد مقتل جندي اخر في
الاشتباكات ويقول انه يواصل تزويد قواته
البريه بالامداد
اللازمه شهدان فلسطينيان برصاص الاحتلال
في القدس وجنوب الخليل والاحتلال يعتقل
عشرات الفلسطينيين في مدن وقرى الضفه
الغربيه بينهم الاسيره المحرره عهد
التميمي في حين يطالب وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي باقامه مناطق عازله حول
مستوطنات الضفه ومنع
الفلسطينيين من الاقتراب منها الى
اللقاء l